alors moi j'adore me casser ça sur la
tête alors ne le faites pas chez vous
[Applaudissements]
incroyable c'est incroyable
qui m'appelle Jean Rachid kalouche
t'inquiète
[Applaudissements]
avec la tête
pourquoi tu as pas fait ça avec le mec
du MMA
c'est tout dans la tête direct
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut rester sur la main
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
toujours de la maison tu vas pas
t'arrêter maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va il faut sucer
tu veux essayer de voir je pense pas non
sur la tête non c'est vrai alors il y a
c'est la seule émission
ou tu as quand même un chroniqueur qui
dit moi je veux bien vous me casser une
sur la tête
après on va dire Hanouna agressif
chroniqueur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]